how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about everything
relating to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and today we have what could be
a very big spoiler for the Black Widow
movie we also have a possible
confirmation that one of the leaked
Black Widow scenes that we've heard
could be true based off of this leak
there has been a big reveal in a leaked
Black Widow Funko pop figurine and it
has a very big crazy detail on it so if
you're trying to avoid all spoilers and
this could be a very big one if true
proceed at your own will and if you
don't want to hear it click away but if
you love staying up-to-date on
everything that is happening with the
MCU be sure to subscribe to my channel
so you don't miss any content and so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Iron Man Funko pop limited-time
figurine I'll be picking a winner on
Monday all you got to do is subscribe
like the video and leave a comment down
below
so speaking of Funko pops as I mentioned
this leak comes from a Black Widow Funko
pop so this figure was leaked before but
we didn't really get a good look at it
and now we have a super clear look at it
and we're not really going to be looking
at the figure of her but we're going to
be looking at the photo of her on the
bottom left in this little cartoon
picture Black Widow is wearing her
sister Yelena's vest and if we look
closely we can see that there's blood on
the vest this is the same vest that
Natasha would later go on to wear an
Infinity Ward and what a lot of people
are thinking and theorizing is that
Yelena will actually die in the movie
and Natasha will go on to wear her vest
and dye her hair in honor of her this
kind of makes sense because many people
were wondering why Natasha
Black Widow had dyed her hair blonde
this was seen to be very very random and
infinity war as black widows red hair is
a signature of hers and infinity war is
literally the only film in the MC where
she has blonde hair so this would offer
a very good explanation for why her hair
was blonde she did it in honor of her
sister because her sister had blonde
hair she also wore her vest and this
becomes even more convincing if we take
a look at this scene in the final
trailer Black Widow is clearly crying
she has her hands on her sister's face
and she brings her head in to touch her
head and it seems like a very very 10
and touching moment but it seems like
both of them are suffering if we look at
Yelena it actually does seem like she
perhaps got shot and is dying and both
of them probably know that she's going
to die which is why black widow is
grabbing her and bringing her in closely
if she does indeed die this is most
likely the scene where Black Widow takes
her vest so Yelena could quite possibly
die in the Black Widow film however she
could perhaps only be making it look
like she died we had a supposedly for a
post-credits scene for the Black Widow
film that you probably heard me talk
about and the leak says that Yelena
actually fakes her death in the film and
the post-credit scene would reveal that
she was actually working for Thunderbolt
Ross the entire time the leak is that
her and taskmaster show up and talked to
Thunderbolt Ross at the end in the
post-credits scene implying that they're
going to go on to join the Thunderbolts
now this would also make a lot of sense
we know the Thunderbolts are coming and
we know that Ross works a lot behind the
scenes and we know that he really wants
that Super Soldier Serum and we know
that the Black Widow movie is going to
focus on that and the Red Room so
perhaps for whatever reason Elena has to
work for Thunderbolt Ross probably
against her will he's most likely going
to throw her in jail if she doesn't
because she was a part of the Red Room
but we honestly don't know if Marvel
would actually kill Jelena there's been
talks of her becoming the next Black
Widow
however Marvel did kill Quicksilver
after one film and he's a major
character in the comics and perhaps
Marvel maybe doesn't want another Black
Widow in the MCU so soon and it would
definitely add for a major shock value
however she could just be faking her
death but Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios did say that Florence
Pugh is going to be a big star and that
probably means that they have some
pretty big plans for her and that she is
in fact going to go on to be the next
Black Widow so it looks like one of
three things is going to happen one is
that nothing really happens to you Lana
and her and Black Widow go their
separate ways
two is that she will actually die in the
film and three is that she'll fake her
death
return in the post-credits scene and
then go on to be a part of the
Thunderbolts I personally would love for
number three to happen because I would
like to see her a part of the
Thunderbolts and her become the next
Black Widow but what would you like to
see happen let me
in the comments down below don't forget
to give the video a like and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU
for live updates you can always follow
me on Twitter and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof